let's continue our tour of this
weekend's 2024 Republican campaign
happenings Ron DeSantis suffered another
woke coma when asked at the roast and
ride event at which Mike Pence also
spoke we'll talk about Mike Pence's
speech tomorrow I think we're just not
going to have time today this was in Des
Moines Iowa
DeSantis went into one another one of
these Comas where he uses the word woke
I mean I don't let's count how many
times he uses it in 30 seconds
[Music]
awoke mind virus represents a war on the
truth so we will wage a war on the woke
we will fight the woken education we
will fight the woke and the corporations
we will fight the woke in the halls of
Congress we will never ever surrender to
the woke mob we will make woke ideology
leave it to the Dustbin of History it's
gone
so that's seven wokes in the first 28
seconds there now has DeSantis ever
defined woke he tried we're going to
look at that a little bit later when we
also look at Nikki Haley's attempt I
think the really we'll we'll talk about
the definition of woke a little bit
later
hear what I want to mention and it's
particularly important if we want to
understand the DeSantis campaign the
whole anti-woke Crusade that the santis
is pushing is rooted in I'm not going to
say fascist ideology it's fascistic
ideology which wants to silence dissent
and uphold whatever right it used to be
we silenced descent and uphold white
supremacy when you look to some prior
fascists uh it could be for whatever
reason at this point we want to silence
Progressive voices or we want to silence
LGBT voices or whatever and so he's
using this fascistic fear-mongering and
of course misinformation to demonize
those who challenge desantis's narrow
and extraordinarily biased view of what
the world and how the country's supposed
to operate and so he will label any
attempt to teach or to learn about
history and reality of racism and
oppression and all these things he will
limit it that's what he does and of
course it completely ignores the
educational value the cultural value of
learning about those things and of
diversity and of inclusion he ignores
the harm that these policies have and
the the the the suppressive and
oppressive impact on speech that they
push forward and so the DeSantis
anti-woke obsession
is not only fascistic in its Origins I
believe it's also bad strategy because
it doesn't reflect the views or or
interests of even if you don't want to
say of most Americans of roughly half of
Americans according to recent polls a
majority of Americans support teaching
about racism support teaching slavery in
schools oppose Banning books that deal
with those issues a majority of
Americans more than ever before support
LGBT rights and immigration reform and
voting rights all of that stuff is
actually as popular or more popular than
any other positions on those issues and
so DeSantis ends up alienating himself
from mainstream public opinion and
Catering to a fringe base that's driven
by fear and resentment and scapegoating
and bigotry we know all this the
question is will obsessing about this
stuff allow DeSantis to appear to be a
leader rather than just the demagogue
and if the voters of the Republican
Party want a demagogue they've got their
guy already and it's Trump so it's not
particularly good strategy totally a
laughing stock truly
if you deal with anxiety or depression
you may have tried meditation exercise
diet changes therapy all of which are
important things to try there is also a
new treatment that we've been talking
about on the program for years which for
many people has been a game changer and
that is ketamine therapy the research
around ketamine therapy for anxiety and
depression looks very promising which is
why I'm thrilled about our new sponsor
mind Bloom mind Bloom is the leader in
at home ketamine therapy having safely
helped thousands of people with anxiety
and depression it's delivered to your
door it's done from the comfort of your
home and unlike traditional talk therapy
ketamine Works quickly and doesn't have
the unpleasant side effects of
traditional antidepressants in a study
of over 1200 mind Bloom clients 89
reported improve movements in their
anxiety and depression after just two
sessions read about the evidence for
ketamine therapy we've talked about it
on the show it's pretty remarkable stuff
mind Bloom is offering my audience a
hundred dollars off your first six
session program
go to mindbloom.com Pacman use the code
Pacman the link is in the description